there are lots of new features in the
new Goodyear blimp the old airship was
built on 1930s technology was redone in
the 60s but the new ship is more like an
airplane flying experience in this
airship versus the old one is almost 180
degrees out the old one being old
technology for feedback controls
literally cables that go out to the pins
where you have a wheel on the side you
have rudder pedals that you're pushing
to this one where it's almost like a big
video game with the joystick controls
all electronic feedback with the older
ship you have basically 20 people
running at you trying to get the airship
onto the ground and stabilize it then
they hold the airship into the wind so
that it can get on the masts and sit
there for the night the older ships they
travel with 22 people it's going to be
five pilots and 15 to 16 crew members
now with the newer airship we're going
to be able to travel with a little bit
less crew probably around 14 or 15 we
have five pilots on each operation 15
pilots in the company with those five
pilots only two can be in the airship so
the other three are monitoring whether
any sort of changes in weather and
anything that may pop up in order to be
a good blimp pilot you have to have
patience once you're in the air you
aren't going anywhere fast we take off
we could be in the air from anywhere
from six hours all the way to 14 15
hours the max endurance on this airship
is 48 hours in the air the blimps are
certified to fly up to 10,000 feet
but generally we fly about a thousand
1,500 feet above the ground depending on
the operation speeds between 30 and 40
miles an hour
one of the things that's really unique
to this airship is the truck in the
connection point to the ground itself
the mass truck is the only thing that's
really attaching it to the ground the
really unique part about an airship
versus a regular airplane helicopter or
something else is that when it gets on
the ground it's still flying and because
of that we have to be really careful how
we treat it even when it's looked to the
ground support equipment because any
kind of a wind shift or movement nothing
is going to want to move with the wind
flying the blimp isn't really like
flying any other aircraft it's more like
flying a boat really there's really no
numbers that you fly like you would in
an airplane or helicopter weather
conditions and wind and everything
impacts the airship so much that you
really have to literally feel each
takeoff and each landing and actually
fly the aircraft